what up reject nation we are gonna watch today the
jurassic world dominion trailer number two before
we hop into that greg why are you wearing a spider
man shirt because today's video sponsor is spider
tanks it is and spider tanks if you don't know is
a brand new pvp brawler from our friends at gala
games and award-winning developer game media
whether you're going up against a few friends
or taking on players around the globe you're
gonna have a blast with this game choose your
tank body add weapons and play to earn upgrades
that you yourself own and are free to sell trade
and even collect rewards i want to say collect
rewards on thanks to the games blockchain base web
3 construction i thought i said it better the free
beta is live right now live so head on out right
down to our link in the description and start
building and owning your own armory with spider
tanks think now would be a good time
to move on we should move on to the
blue had a video that's impossible hey girl
anything's possible this world life uh finds a way
we made a terrible mistake finally you admit
this wednesday clock might be about out of time
man bigger and better
oh ouch clotheslined
this is gonna be insane
i could use your expertise goddamn
right you can't of course you could
a baby raptor i made a promise we would bring
her home everyone's doing to a dinosaur yeah
everybody hold on to somebody
wow this is gonna be beautiful
man i love the feathers right
no
biggest carnivore the world has ever seen
ah like a good dino crisis that was like just
on par with the first truth these trailers they
feel like you can just watch their own little
short films so good like we should cherish
these moments because you know no matter how
the movie is which i'm expecting good things
but these trailers have just been so much
fun to watch i'm rooting for the dinosaurs
i'm rooting for them to take over how baller of a
move would that be if the dinosaurs are the ones
who ultimately take over earth who have dominion
oh my goodness that would just be such a bold
ending yeah man it'd be like every horror movie
where the slasher wins and then it's like a small
band of misfit humans have to band together in
order to survive and continue on the human race
mad max jurassic world and i would love if the
dinosaurs can learn to like communicate with
humans in some way that's even
clearer sign language with claws
so brilliant they're putting their humans in so
many situations you have so much set up for so
many different occasions of danger and where they
have to survive things where any time i see the
setup in any of these little snippets i go how the
hell are they going to survive that how could they
possibly survive that situation but they're going
to and it's going to be freaking off yeah the
more impossible these get somehow the more like
legitimized they try to make them well there's a
couple of things here that i think they are going
to do in terms of character development which is
something i didn't think i'd be saying for a while
with this franchise but i think they're going to
be doing it bringing back the old crew you know
alan grant ellie malcolm you're bringing them back
you know like they have that conversation with
owen uh or at least the way the trailer splices
it together a baby raptor again him having a deal
with baby raptors i love it absolutely love it the
baby t-rex and the lost world that jeff goldblum
had to deal with the raptor eggs and jurassic park
i love it absolutely love it i adore it they're
all like you you made a promise to a raptor about
it showing that they are not attuned at all
to the evolution of communication that could
possibly happen with really having a bond with
the dinosaurs like animals you know what i mean
so i think that is going to be part of their
learning lesson because there's even one shot
there where you see that dr grant is part of it
where they are trying to like calm a rapture i
think it is the blues daughter their daughter or
son i forgot i think it's daughter what does it
matter it's a blues local times it's gotta be a
daughter so it's uh blue's child down so i think
dr grant is really gonna have to learn like oh
even with the carnivorous ones there's a way to
create a relationship with them i think that's
gonna be like a fun part of it that could be
cheesy or it could be cool so it looks like an
old dog can learn new tricks from our little boy
owen you know what i mean that's right man owen
is gonna take that old fogey franchise uh veteran
he's gonna turn him into a compassionate
accepting raptor lover it's gonna be great
yes and then you know with blue's child getting
kid poached at the beginning of this we don't
know why it's kind of like a children of men
scenarios that's where's the left how can you
it's like how how is the raptor able to have a
child how did this happen it's going to make it
something that's more personally involved now
i raise those stakes are they traversing the
world to find this this child yes that way they're
going everywhere that's why it's a universal movie
that speaks to everyone is because it's all just
about trying to find your lost kid and to rekindle
that love and show them that you care i i i'm
sensing sarcasm i've never sarcastically where
i was actually asking a very genuine question
sure and even dr henry wu who went like full
villain like just full villain in the last
two this is a matter of perspective man
even in this trailer you're seeing he's got a
sense of remorse here oh yeah whoa how we made it
too far yeah what are we gonna we're so busy
wondering if we could we didn't ask if we
should it's almost like auctioning them off
to a bunch of rich [ __ ] in the last movie
it was a bad idea i finally considered that
when you know maybe rich people shouldn't have
these things to point at each other almost as if
this would be impossible to keep under control
and it took them like breaking out and taking
over the entire world to get the point of garage
at least in this trailer it's showing that claire
and i think that character's name is macy little
clone girl yeah i know and are living together
yeah they're a family they're a real family
as opposed to the way how the other two were
set up where owen and claire are not together
and then she has to go talk to him and
he's like get away i'm doing something
manly right now yeah man i'm building my house
and now he's doing manly thing here as a family
lou get back to blue's family and by the end
they're all going to be one big family and then
they'll probably have coronas with the original
cat and then what's gonna happen the old team
you know malcolm grant and ellie are gonna be
criticizing the type of methods that owen has
and then james gunn's going to step in and
defend the hell out of him owen grady is very
compassionate towards all dynamics whatever you've
heard about owen has it no from someone else and
you are just shocked you were just believing lies
right owen's a great guy and he knows that these
two actions speak for themselves all right owen is
a lover of all people and dinosaurs alike bottom
line is like they showed us uh stuff with our
characters which is just really the cherry on top
to all the crazy dinosaur mayhem this beautiful
trailer i've never been happier my entire life
i just want to train a t-rex now man yeah i
just want to do the forced push of dinosaurs
all right guys well thank you so much for being
here uh this was a true pleasure let's do a
pandemic jones pandemic jones you know what i
want to see is a pandemic that happens but it's
a bunch of pjs that have been cloned you that's
your initials i'm not talking about pajamas
i'm talking about you pj spread everywhere and
then we're gonna be like oh man this has gone
too far there's too many pjs we thought this
would be a great idea because pj is such a nice
guy so if we spread out pj everywhere across the
globe we would probably have the most beautiful
pandemic of all where everyone will be more kind
considerate compassionate but the thing is when
there's too much of anything it just becomes
annoying after a while it's not gonna be the
thing we hope for where it's just it's gonna get
to a point we're all gonna be like shut up because
what's gonna go wrong here pjs you're not gonna
have a hive mind everyone talks at the same time
like when one talks as you just hear it's just
a loud echo of just all pjs around the world
eventually it's just all dominating but you
know what you're gonna be dominant pj you're
gonna be the purest original pj and you're the
only one who doesn't have to talk along with
the hive mind bottom line is this is going to be
terrible for us but great for you so thanks for
being here and being a super sexy reject annoying
our lives but making our lives a better place